meet Sarah Sarah is a sales professional
who schedules a lot of meetings with
co-workers and clients she is also a
tungle user tungle is a calendar
accelerator that Sarah has synced with
her existing calendar so that she can
easily schedule meetings publish her
free busy schedule and share
calendars here's how it works Marney is
Sarah's client she uses different email
and calendar applications and is in a
different time
zone when Sarah needs to schedule a call
with Marne she opens tungle enters her
meeting
details proposes
times and sends mney receives an email
meeting invitation from
Sarah she's not a tungle user but that's
okay she won't have to sign up to reply
and can even respond from her
smartphone tungle automatically
customizes the invitation from marne's
time zone so she simply picks a time and
books the
call Sarah and Marne both receive email
confirmations and the meeting is
automatically added to Sarah's calendar
just like that the call is
booked but what if Sarah had sent the
invitation and then added new events to
her calendar that overlap time she
proposed to
Marney tungle would have dynamically
updated the meeting invitation so that
Sarah would not be double
booked Sarah has also published her free
busy schedule using her personal tungle
me link which she has added to her email
signature LinkedIn profile and Facebook
page when Marne wants to meet with Sarah
she simply clicks Sarah's link to see
when she's free she can then send Sarah
a meeting invitation proposing multiple
times without having to sign
up Sarah saves so much time scheduling
with Marney that she now uses tongle for
group meetings
too when she wants to meet with her
sales team
she simply creates one invitation and
sends it to everyone it's easy because
she and her team share their calendars
through tungle even though some work
from home and use different calendar
applications so when proposing times
Sarah simply selects her team from her
contact list and can instantly see their
availability overlaid on hers making it
even easier to proposed times with group
meetings each invite gets an invitation
and chooses all the times that work for
them tungle Narrows down the choices and
the last person to reply chooses from
the remaining slots to book the
meeting and that's how tungle makes life
easier for
Sarah so are you ready to
tongle